[Musique]
sa carrière très heureux de vous
retrouver notre invité principal ce soir
c'est christian louboutin
et sur le bulletin un bon soir vous êtes
aujourd'hui christian le plus célèbre
créateur de souliers du monde toutes les
stars portent vos fameuses escarpins à
semelles rouges et je crois que l'on
peut dire que si à 30 ans une femme n'a
pas des louboutin elle a raté sa vie
alors juste un petit sondage dans le
public c'est elle qui serait prête à
tuer pour avoir des louboutin lever la
main
toutes les filles ont fait alors
christian vous connaissez les missions
au père nous serons tous les deux nous
parlerons de vous de vos origines votre
enfance notre vocation de notre
apprentissage de carrière et du tri en
planétaire de vos talents hauts et des
drames que ça cause toutes les 30
secondes dans le monde une cheville ce
brise à cause de vous
en p2 nous accueillerons trois nouveaux
invités pour commentaire avec nous
l'actualité de la semaine jean pierre
coffe pour son nouveau livre recevoir
vos amis à petit prix publié chez plon
l'une des techniques recommandées par
cov c'est de se cacher et de pas bouger
quand les amis sonne à la porte
l'autre c'est de bouffer le chien
toujours en p2 nous recevrons aïssa
maïga et stéphane guillon pour le film
le temps de la kermesse est terminé de
frédéric chignac un film qui se passe en
afrique et qui prouve que le dakar paris
c'est beaucoup plus dur à faire que le
paris dakar en p3 après guillon et
zapper une nous acquérons notre invité
du samedi 20 heures ce soir joël de
ville et pour son livre témoignage
violée par un prêtre aux éditions de
l'arbre le problème c'est que quand on
se fait violer par un curé c'est qu'il
refuse de mettre un préservatif
puisqu'il est fidèle au pape voilà
l'émission s'appelle salut les terriens
mais avant tout
[Musique]
alors question en revanche soir alors la
reine rania de jordanie catherine
deneuve cameron diaz caroline de monaco
nicole kidman
angélina jolie renée zelwegger by and
see dita von teese sofia coppola
victoria beckham madonna britney spears
et jennifer lopez porte vous souliers à
semelles rouges d'ailleurs jennifer
lopez on a fait une chanson on regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
ah
la fin
non
de teint
vesa
jennifer lopez the beauties
en question c'est la gloire mais c'est
surtout la preuve que les femmes ont un
rapport très particulier avec leur
souris oui c'est ça qui me plaît dans la
chance oui vous êtes devenu une fashion
ikon quand je pense que tout est parti
d'une demande mimie mathy qui voulait
avoir une taille normale au départ
non en fait tout a commencé le 7 janvier
1964 vous naissez à paris dans un
quartier populaire le 12e arrondissement
votre mère irène vous élève vous et vos
quatre soeurs et votre père roger est
ébéniste pour la sncf famille modeste
d'origine bretonne et vous vous avez un
air métis dans une famille très blanche
vous êtes jamais demandé pourquoi c'est
bien sûr je me bouge on se pose toujours
des questions sur le facteur mais c'est
en voyant des cousins du côté de mon
père que je vais arrêter de penser aux
facteurs à un moment vous invitiez
impasse égyptien pour justifier sa non
oui tout à fait comme j'avais l'air même
plus métis que maintenant j'étais
persuadé que j'étais égyptiens alors
vous grandissez dans un monde de femmes
vous êtes le petit dernier donc les
soeurs parle de tous devant vous ce qui
fait que j'étais vraiment comme au
théâtre je regardais et j'avais des
grandes soeurs qui faisait leur numéro
les problèmes et téléphone et financé
les mensonges et tout est mais j'étais
pas considéré comme une comme une vision
masculine et c'était rigolo et c'est de
là que date votre vénération des femmes
absolument alors à 12 ans vous réfugiez
souvent au musée des arts africains et
océaniens qui à l'époque s'appelait
encore le musée des colonies porte dorée
vous découvrez l'exotisme vous attrapez
votre goût des voyages et là un jour
vous voyez un idéogramme une chaussure à
talon
barré d'une croix rouge qui interdisait
en fait le musée aux talons aiguilles
c'est ce dessin qui m'a fait comprendre
que tout est dessiné que dans le fond on
ne sait pas forcément quand on est un
enfant mais tout ce qu'on voit tout ce
qui hélas était dessiné la chaise a été
desserrée votre costume le micro le
bureau la frise précise a été dessiné
les lumières ont été faites tout est
dessiné alors cela en regardant ce
dessin je me suis dit tiens c'est drôle
on peut même dessiner des souliers de
femmes et donc à la base c'était plutôt
un c'était un hobby c'était presque un
tic va redessiner toujours ce dessin et
ses thématiques je pensais pas du tout
que c'était un métier rechute quand vous
voyez une prostituée à la foire du trône
avec des talents au vous flashé sur elle
et on prenait un coup de pied dans le
cul du mak koidu souteneur oui je vois
ses souliers ce dessin qui s'était mis à
exister qu'était sur les pieds de
quelqu'un mais c'était vraiment comme un
dessin animé pour même j'ai suivi mais
j'ai suivi vraiment les souliers quoi
j'ai suivi des talons et un moment on
m'a attrapé de dos et on m'a donné un
grand coup de pied dans les faits si on
m'a dit tu dégages alors je les fais
vous dit si j'avais vu une signalétique
interdisant les tracteurs je serais
devenu constructeur de matériel agricole
absolument c'était vraiment l'univers du
dessin qui m'intéressait et c'était
aussi quand même le rapport à la danse
et aux femmes mais c'était pas la mode
clairement pas c'était c'était vraiment
ce dessin alors à l'école dont vous êtes
le fou qui décide des souliers toute la
journée sur les cahiers sur les pupitres
exactement il y avait cette publicité de
guy degrenne on voyait un enfant qui
devait avoir était plus jeune qui devais
avoir 8 ans et puis le professeur
longueuil en disant ah monsieur guy
degrenne vous serez jamais rien et on
regarde ce cahier de dessin qui était
donc découvert est alors à cause de
cette publicité on me disait toujours il
se prend pour guy degrenne
alors à l'âge de 14 ans vous commencé à
déserter les bancs de l'école pour les
fêtes de la main bleue du palace vous
rencontré votre bande d'amis farida eva
ionesco pieds agiles à saison dans
l'école de couture l'académie road
horreur et puis vous devenez stagiaires
aux folies bergères et là vous offrez
des croquis au meneuse de revue lisette
malidor rita renoir norma duval vous
êtes fasciné par l'hyper féminité de ces
femmes ce qui est sûr c'est qu'une femme
on les danseuses particulièrement mais
une femme dès qu'elle se met sur les
talons
la silhouette se redessine complètement
la silhouette par en avant le centre de
gravité basculer donc le corps cambre
les fesses partent en arrière la pâte la
poitrine plonge en avant donc ça fait un
dessin comme ça et qu'ils se disent
qu'ils se finit par juste une petite
goutte c'est très joli vous dites la
ligne d'une femme part du duo des
cuisses et va jusqu'à la pointe des
pieds visuellement quand on regarde une
danseuse la ligne de la jambe elle
commence à la hanche et elle descend
jusqu au décolleté ce qu'on appelle le
décolleté du pied c'est à dire la partie
avant où s'arrête le soulier donc le
décolleté profond la jambe et voilà
c'est le secret
[Applaudissements]
alors christian a 18 ans quand vous
dites qu'il est temps de travailler pour
de vrai vous ouvrez le bottin à maison
de couture vous appeler chez balmain la
personne répond vous appeler chez dior
la directrice hélène de mortemart qui
vous propose d'aller apprendre le boulot
en fait chez jours dans un roman qui est
la capitale la chaussure et de la
gontrie en france ensuite vous dessinez
des chaussures freelance vous vendez vos
dessins saint laurent à chanel en 1991
vous créez votre société et un an plus
tard anna wintour c'est à dire la
directrice de vogue celle qui a été
croqué dans le diable s'habille en prada
passez la porte de votre boutique est là
s'est lancé quoi elle flashe sur vos ce
qui s'est passé c'est que moi je n'étais
pas du tout au point quand les acheteurs
américains sont arrivés ils venaient
pour acheter l'hiver c'était l'été
il me dit baye à cet hiver là c'est quoi
ce jeudi c'est l'hiver mais c'est
l'année dernière c'est fini dans un mois
10 monde s'en fout personnes vous
connaît dit oui mais c'est vieux déjà ah
mais non ces vieux pour vous mais c'est
nouveau pour tous
alors j'ai dit bon bah écoutez et ça m'a
finalement facilité ma première
collection et puis en fait a été revendu
un an après
la touche finale en fait ce sera les
semelles rouges une fille qui je
travaillais qui venait essayer les
souliers alors c'était pas un énorme
boulot parce que quand les souliers tout
cas essayé elle était là tout petit peu
à se raser alors comme elle sera elle se
faisait les ongles alors je lui ai
attrapé son vernis à ongles et puis j'ai
coloré la semaine et je me suis dit je
vais faire les semaines de couleur au
départ voulait faire différentes
couleurs en fait je pensais faire une
couleur par saison ouais et puis tout de
suite c'est devenu une identité j'ai
fait tout de suite la semelle rouge est
immédiatement des femmes sont revenus
dans le magasin et 10ème et c'est génial
je me suis fais draguer je me rappelle
cette femme qui avait dit mais c'est un
vous savez mais vos souliers c'est les
aspirateurs aminé cela formidable
et en fait c'était c'est vrai que c'est
comme un dialogue tel qu'on se retourne
sur une femme et c'est un signal un feu
vert rouge voilà
ça vaut combien une paire de louboutin
ça commence à
450 euros et puis ça peut aller à
suivant les matières ça peut aller à
très très cher c'est à dire que je crois
qu'une paire de bottes en crocodile ce
qui doit être à peu près ce qui est plus
cher doit coûter 15 mille euros
aujourd'hui christian vous avez des
points de vente dans le monde entier une
usine en italie une maison à louxor un
voilier sur le nil et les barbies
louboutin et des barbies l'aube ou tard
maintenant alors latex et wells bien à
geler
donc en fait vous allez continuer à
dessiner des chaussures là mais oui je
continue au dessous de votre vie vous
aurez fait ce à quoi toute ma vie durant
pour l'instant oui absolument vous avez
décidé combien de modèles pour le moment
chaque collection je commence avec
506 en croquis qui descendent à 300
prototype et ça arrive à 150 mais disons
deux cents 200 milles j'avais fait deux
cent mille croquis de chaussures
[Applaudissements]
on se rappellera qu'il avait les jambes
quoi
aïssa maïga et stéphane guillon ton
commentaire est tout
[Musique]
vont s'arrêter un rebond soit détails
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
christian louboutin bonsoir
nous accueillons jean pierre coffe
aïssa maïga
déjà une vision
quelle impression ça fait des clashs pas
là c'est bizarre ouais j'espère que je
peux dire autant de saloperies si je
peux dire tout ce que tu
alors jean pierre coffe bonsoir bonsoir
les lunettes c'est un stock que vous
avez racheté elton john
en fait c'est la seule solution pour que
le public de drucker vous repère
alors ça va chez michel je mange bien je
crois que ça va bien ça va bien ouais
moi c'est une bonne petite émission à
l'ancienne c'est bien l'ancien il vaut
mieux ça que des émissions trop moderne
et
[Applaudissements]
jean-pierre c'est ici ce soir pour nous
parler de votre nouveau livre recevoir
vos amis à petit prix publié chez plon
200 recettes pas trop cher pour
continuer à recevoir ses amis malgré la
crise d'abord faut des amis
ouais faut pas avoir trop d'amis non
plus parce que ça coûte cher non ça va
tomber non ça coûte pas cher qu'il ya
des plats à 0,50 centimes par personne
même du vin bon marché j'ai long plus le
livre est à 9 euros 90 tout
se fait vite le maximum de proue ajoute
les banderilles arrive il faut avoir des
vrais avis parce que comme ça et vous
dise pas que c'est mauvais mais c'est
des trucs que je fais pour recevoir mes
propres amis mans or journée depuis 40
ans le même quai gradins alors il ya un
chapitre entier consacré aux abats le
titre et les ahbache même ça on partage
parce que vous n'êtes pas amateur de
rognons blancs vous
devriez essayer plus souvent verriez que
c'est pas mal du tout enfin quoi c'est
c'est formidable les abats l'onglet
tabac à l'onglet la ram et oui la hampe
est un abat ça faisait partie du
cinquième quartier un onglet qui à 27
jours de racisme en vous le coupez à la
fourchette ces deux là soient nature jeu
est magnifique on dirait le boutin qui
parle de ses chaussures c'est
extraordinaire alors la plupart des
recettes sur le bout de souffle et
dessert qu'ils sont inspirés des livres
de restriction par dupont la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est que soit donné un
boost au mans 42 voulait dire attendez
là autour de moi je n'ai que des gamins
vous n'avez pas connu la guerre non bon
noël pendant la guerre c'est une orange
où mon vieux il n'y avait rien d'autre
on a bu une orange embannet dans d'un
vieux papier d'aluminium qui était un
truc d'une vie tablettes de la faduc les
les américains viennent en france et
traverse la lorraine pour que je mange
pour la première fois du chocolat de ma
vie en 45 avec un gâteau de pommes de
terre sucré on se régalait comme des
fous un jour je viendrai vous le faire
si ça vous amuse non non
écoute franchement tu as tort je te jure
que c'est très très bon d'un gâteau de
carottes ça coûte rien c'est vachement
bon il faut un peu de cannelle et hop et
voilà on s'éclate je t'aime de l'époque
en fait comme les gens ont plus de
pognon actuellement un couple au smic
avec deux enfants il lui reste huit
euros 34 8 euros 34 par jour pour manger
midi et soir plus le petit déjeuner et
vous avez recevez vous braves manger du
steak tous les gens me disent oim donc
moi c'est ces gens là que je défends à
16 ans le plaisir à petit prix s'est
vendu à 400 mille exemplaires un
bilan à votre petite entreprise ne
connaît pas la crise ce serait pas plus
utile pour le consommateur d'utiliser
votre pouvoir médiatique pour vous
attaquer la grande distribution puisque
c'est un scandale et j'y suis dans la
garniture encore savez vous avez bouffé
l'argent bon allez vers price bien sûr
que je les manger et alors on est en
train de refaire inquiet
mais thierry ardisson j'ai été engagé
pour ça en a reçus à quelques semaines
agriculteurs qu'ils nous disaient qu'ils
vendent et ses pommes 17 centimes d'euro
et qu'ils y retrouvent en vente dans les
supermarchés à 3 euros le kilo c'est
qu'à moi cette grande distribution et je
renvoie tout le monde à l'article du
point cette semaine c'est terrible c'est
cela la chimie s'il vend ses pommes 0 17
centimes d'euro il peut bouffer chekhov
à ce prix là
[Applaudissements]
je suis d'accord avec vous le problème
des fruits et des légumes est un
problème qui est difficilement
c'est pas facile à résoudre si vous
voulez dans la mesure où
il ya une distribution centrale vous
savez qu'un fruit dans une assiette
aujourd'hui a parcouru en moyenne
2500 km mais je sais ça royal mais mais
ça c'est pas ça qui me choque le plus
c'est que en france on achète et on
laisse faire on laisse acheter des
fruits qui viennent d'afrique du sud ou
d'amérique du sud et qui avant d'arriver
ici on fait si - chambre froide c'est ça
qui me révolte je viens de faire une
étude pour madame pécresse comme vous
avez pu voir sur le ce que mangent les
étudiants dans les crous les pommes est
centralisé il ya un organisme qui
achètent pour tous les crous de france
ils achètent la pomme un euro elles sont
en vente à 30 centimes actuellement dans
l'orléanais des pommes premier choix qui
ont pas fait de frigo du tout mais moi
je peux pas lutter contre ça c'est pas
moi je suis pas le patron des crous je
ne suis pas mme élise très en forme vous
êtes beau être conservateur
je suis malheureusement bourré de pas
grand chose je le regrette
aïssa et stéphane rebond soir alors
stéphane ce n'est pas le guillon qui
fait sa revue de presse en p3 sur salut
les terriens que nous recevons ce soir
ce n'est pas le guillon qui triomphe sur
scène aux deux jaser et dont le
spectacle est complet jusqu'à la fin mai
alors nous recevons ce soir le guillon
acteurs en effet vous êtes tous les deux
à l'affiché d'un film qui s'appelle le
temps de la kermesse un film de frédéric
chignac un film dans lequel un homme
blanc rencontre une salle noire à la
première question qui joue l'homme blanc
qui joue
d'accord j'aime bien ce début en tout
cas c'est le cycle est très claire les
gens vont pas être les marques blanc
d'accord le pitch donc alex keller c'est
vous tombe en panne de voiture dans un
village misérable du désert africain
il y a là des habitants désoeuvrés qu'il
paye pour un nas ablement faire
redémarrer sa voiture rien le patron
d'un petit bar avec qui discutent en
éclusant des bières il ya le vieux chef
du village qui a combattu pour la france
mais qui a jamais eu sa pension il ya
une femme seule martine assez vous et
qui veulent en france en fait c'est son
obsession c'est elle en france ce
village en fête c'est un microcosme qui
résume l'afrique c'est un conte moderne
sur les rapports nord-sud ce film c'est
assez bien réussie d'ailleurs c'est vrai
que c'est un personnage raciste assez
veulent assez désagréable qui aussi des
côtes qui est qu'il ya une lucidité
qu'il saute c'est à dire qu'il connaît
parfaitement l'afrique il connaît
parfaitement les rapports nord-sud
il est assez honnête avec avec cette
fille martine à dire qu'il lui dit que
si elle va en france elle finira sur le
trottoir parce qu'il m'a intéressé dans
le film c'est que le personnage d'alex
arif dans ce village avec ses certitudes
et petit à petit du fait de la panne et
du fait qu'il ne peut pas redémarrer
qu'il ne peut pas repartir il est obligé
de tisser des liens avec des gens que
d'habitude il il méprise et c'est
l'occasion de découvrir notamment en
personnage martil acquis une fille qui a
priori est une victime c'est une femme
qui parle peu qui vient lui faire à
manger et petit à petit on découvre
qu'elle a un projet alors son projet ne
lui appartient pas elle seule sait aussi
le projet de toute une communauté de la
du village qui décide ce sera elle qui
va assurer l'avenir de la famille
élargie et les soutiens de famille alors
avec cela saute
la vieille ouais voilà c'est ça la scène
est très poignante en fait parce que
c'est fini sur votre visage on vous voit
pas on voit juste votre visage on voit
pleurer c'est très touchant on a un
petit peu imposée vouliez pas être tout
nu c'est un black âmes prudes
savoie
et en tout 7 rue de la lys à un bon ce
n'est pas avec dix on compare et on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
deux pas des potiches
mais
faute de main de noyon je peux pas
rester ici plus longtemps ça va revenir
si ça marche pas je me flatte sa soeur
c'est donc aussi c'est pas grand chose
dans ce pays circulez rien à voir c'est
juste un blanc qui vous ça va continuer
mais trois fois par jour le baril vous
allez vous avez le coup sinon comment tu
t'appelles markine
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est ton choix
du coup encore
climatique a vaincu c'est le conflit
n'est pas appris ça c'est du chantage ça
fait des siècles que le monde vous
entube jose en choper un vous êtes bien
raison de plus n'est
là on peut dire mais parce que leur lit
ben martin à je vais aller en france
elle doit partir c'est pas une bonne
idée il vaut mieux cadrer si si tu
ferais quoi en france c'est fait alors
est ce qu'un pied ferme et
des mécaniciens ça fait 15 jours qu'on
pousse et le dit maintenant que les
mécaniciens ce que tu veux encore qui
est bien avec toi mais votre avis sur la
question mais ce que m quelle question
l'avenir de cette afrique que vous aimez
très facile je n'ai pas de temps à
perdre et un concours aujourd'hui un ca
ce qui manquera le plus
j'étais en france on passerait pas la
frontière je dois aider le filage
voilà le temps la kermesse est terminé
de frédéric chignac avec alyson hannigan
et stéphane guillon à l'oreille du pot
parce qu'en fait c'est poelvoorde qui
devait faire le film oui et c'est plutôt
une bonne affaire pour vous heureusement
vous avez pas fait astérix aux jeux
olympiques paraguay c'est vrai que j'ai
campings 4 c'est vrai que j'ai hésité
maintenant que stéphane guillon à 7
cette
importance médiatique
je trouve que c'est tout à fait
formidable d'avoir au cinéma parce que
c'est très inattendu moi je trouve que
c'est passionnant d'aller le voir dans
un tout autre métier finalement je suis
un [ __ ] quand même là aussi
j'essaie vraiment de rester dans les
annales fidèle à moi-même quoi ne pas
décevoir les gens
jusqu'à dire aux gens que ce que ce film
a été boudé par tous les festivals
possibles et imaginables parce que le
propos dérange qui l'a été quand même
encensé par la critique notamment le
canard enchaîné les actions cette
semaine que c'est un film et télérama
c'est un film qui a très peu de salles
et donc s'ils vont pas tout de suite là
après l'émission ils pourront plus voir
donc un jeu sorte d'urgence aller voir
ce film ne serait ce que pour faire un
bras d'honneur aussi à tous les gens qui
sont frileux dans ce pays et ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux m
le raïs âgé vous laisser filer mais
avant je voulais poser la question que
tout le monde se pose etes-vous
célibataire et quelle est votre feuille
et quelle est votre attitude dans le
calme et la dignité merci beaucoup pour
ce rallye
un drap gable a
rien à faire c'est la question pour la
faire partir c'est bien d'avoir une
question pour faire partir en même temps
quand il veut tous les ans alors on
passe maintenant commentaire de
l'actualité de la semaine et je voudrais
préciser qu'en raison des élections
régionales de mywi c'est les élections
régionales demain nous ne pouvons pas
parler politique ce soir voilà dont nous
parlerons alimentation ça très bien mon
cher coffre et c'est fabrice nicolino
l'auteur du livre bidoche l'industrie de
la viande menace le monde que nous
retrouverons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto
[Musique]
bon j'ai du steak haché va-t-il devenir
un crime pas quoi c'est pas l'innocent
il a bien failli la tuer cette vache bon
dimanche et son cadavre à 5,7 contre la
chasse à courre contre la corrida c'est
la barbarie en revanche les animaux
d'élevage réduit à l'esclavagé envoyer à
l'abattoir on les extermine ça ne nous
pose pas de problème et va pas d'appétit
mais non personne ne cherche plus pas
visé la seule chose c'est que si vous
continuez à bouteville tes cachets et
ben on va tous crever le réchauffement
de la planète vous avez entendu parler
est ce que vous aviez que l'industrie de
la viande produits plus de gaz à effet
de serre que l'industrie des transports
une vache qui rote émettent du méthane
un gaz 23 fois plus polluant que le co2
qui sort du pot d'échappement d'un 4 4
et le pire c'est que les terriens
mangent de plus en plus de viande
dans les pays en voie de développement
ils en mangent même deux fois plus ya 20
ans c'est qu'on s'enrichit ont fait un
bond bifteck standing chez nous pas
forcément ça serait plutôt la mer ce
avec la crise la consommation de viande
a baissé de 3% ces deux dernières années
la france toujours là pour tonique
c'est l hélico de blacko mise en images
dieu julien grave alors fabrice nicolino
bonsoir
donc 1 pén à cigarette l'alcool et
toutes les autres drogues on va nous
interdire l'entrecôte
si on continue à manger de la viande
c'est la fin du monde non mais c'est
vrai un seul terrible pour prendre les
choses dans l'ordre d'abord les bêtes
d'élevage sont traités de façon
scandaleuse
on coupe le bec des poules on jette les
pauvres petits poussins mâles à la
poubelle les cochons sont édenté enfin
c'est vrai que les chaînes d'abattage
ccd lieu de torture bon seulement
confirmé c'est pas seulement l'abattage
c'est les conditions de l'élevage passe
de l'élevage industriel je vous prends
un exemple il ya des fermiers des
porcheries industrielles où il ya cent
mille port par cent mille 100 milles ça
représente les déjections de 500000
habitants vous rendez compte ensuite on
est obligé obligé pour avoir des les
rendements voulu de leur d'orage et des
antibiotiques de leur injectent des
hormones de leur injecter toutes sortes
de médicaments de rang des faits de leur
couper le bec parce que dans les comptes
dans ces conditions de proxim de
promiscuité se battent se bouffent des
cochons se bouffent cochon moi j'ai vu
pire on leur donne des ballons et
ballons gonflés comme ça pour qu'il
s'amuse parce qu'ils sont dans un
univers totalement concentrationnaire
comme les maisons de retraite un peu
[Rires]
non c'est pire que ça écoutez moi je le
connais bien et maisons de retraite non
pas pour lui même s'il cherchait la
vôtre
non la mienne et août chez drucker c'est
sympa comme maison de retraite
vous verrez que je finirai par y arriver
le problème actuellement c'est que
l'animal en stabulation ivo 3500 euros
de subventions et celui qui est à
l'herbe niveau 350 euros dont plus
personne n'a envie de conserver des
prairies sur des centaines d'hectares
pour pouvoir élever des bêtes c'est ça
qui fait défaut en premier point faut
voir comment tous ces anisé la barbarie
sont élevés mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
le deuxième point c'est que la
consommation de viande afin de la
planète dire que les céréales qui sont
produites en fait dans le monde elles
nourrissent pas les gens qui ont faim
mais nourrissent le bétail que les
riches vont manger exactement 70 % des
surfaces agricoles sont destinés à
nourrir le bétail soit sous la forme de
pâturage ça sous un forme de terre qui
porte des céréales qui vont nourrir le
bétail il ya un milliard d'affamés
chronique sur terre en ce moment on
parle et si la consommation de viande
qui continue à augmenter ce sera
probablement le cas à cause de la
consommation dans les pays qu'on appelle
émergents vraisemblablement il y aura à
l'avenir 2 3 et peut-être davantage 2
milliard d'affamés chronique est
effectivement dans les pays émergents
manger de la viande c'est un signe
extérieur de richesse si vous allez en
chine aujourd'hui dans une famille
d'accueil des découpes des couches
moyennes chinoises urbain vous aurez le
à table sur la table au moins six plats
de viande parce que c'est un signe
extérieur de richesse pour cultiver ses
céréales ont détruit des forêts on
exproprie des cultivateurs et c'est
l'animal c'est un très mauvais
transformateurs d'énergie pourra obtenir
une calorie animale il faut entre 7 et 9
calories végétales donc il faut
énormément de céréales et de végétaux
pour nourrir les animaux donc ça serait
plus plus évident de nourrir les gens
avec des régimes à base de végétaux qui
soit dit en passant sont meilleurs pour
la santé
plutôt que de s'acharner à consommer une
viande qui pose des problèmes de santé
publique de plus en plus et volant alors
autre point la viande c'est une
catastrophe écologique parce que les
mission de gaz à effet de serre ça
qu'aujourd'hui les animaux produisent
plus de gaz à effet de serre qu les
transports c'est extraordinaire c'est 18
% et 14 % un kilo de boeuf quand vous
bouffer un kilo de boeuf c'est comme si
vous roulez trois plombes en bagnole en
laissant toutes allumées chez vous avant
de partir ça c'est d'un côté c'est vrai
c'est vrai et puis à l'eau aussi il faut
25 litres d'eau pour faire 100 g de blé
et 25 mille litres d'eau pour faire 100
g de 9,6 à paulilles ou parce que les
nappes phréatiques sont toutes polluées
à cause des nitrates quoi se dire c'est
évident faut vraiment faut vraiment à
être gonflé nos politiques le son vous
faut être gonflé pour faire semblant de
découvrir le problème des algues vertes
par un parent bretagne alors que tout a
été dit écrit j'ai des dizaines de
rapports chez moi sur les algues vertes
leur origine enfin ça vient de là zot on
veut dire très grossièrement pour moitié
ça vient des déjections de la merde de
de la volaille des porcs et des bovins
industriels pour moitié on le sait
depuis au moins 30 ans on n'a rien fait
du tout et là on re découvre patty hewes
des problèmes et désintoxication on
avait découvert en plus que les algues
on se décompose en créer d d d émission
de gaz sulfurés très nocive et donc on
redécouvre à nouveau ce problème là et
on fait et on fait semblant de
s'émouvoir alors la troisième fois tout
cas c'est terrible ça ça donne plus
envie de bouffer de la viande 1 cc
jean-pierre vous devriez le lire ce
livre ça mais j'ai tout à fait
d'attraction de lire moi j'ai la banane
énorme steak tartare amis ne
sent pas très bien
que ça fait quelles solutions
préconisez-vous quand même est-ce qu'il
faudrait bon le mais les évidences et il
faudrait manger le mois et en plus c'est
relativement facile parce que la
consommation de viande de rappeler comme
la france elle a à peu près à peu près
triplé depuis 50 ans donc on mange on
arrange beaucoup trop de viande est-ce
qu'il faut taxer la viande baril serait
une très bonne idée rex baffe très
travaillé très très bonne idée allons-y
pour une taxe ça va faire plaisir à tout
le monde pas moi qui l'annoncent
vraiment qu'ils cherchent à polluer
beaucoup c'est de manger un big mac dans
un drive in dans les santons 4,4 à lui
voilà
bonne idée c'est le maximum que tu
puisses faire on se retrouve après la
pub avec le capi lions est notre invité
du samedi 20 heures ce soir joie de
vivre
on y voit témoignages violée par a
peut-être aux éditions dollar
[Musique]
car bonsoir les terrienne nous sommes
toujours en compagnie de jean pierre
coffe
[Applaudissements]
de christian louboutin
de fabrice nicolino
nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20 heures ce soir joël de ville et donc
pour son livre témoignage
violée par un prêtre aux éditions de
l'arbre alors joël bonsoir ça à un
moment où l'implication indirecte du
frère du pape benoît 16 dans un scandale
de pédophilie en allemagne brac à
nouveau les projecteurs de l'actualité
sur l'église catholique
les éditions de l'arbre réédite votre
livre témoignage violée par un prêtre
l'histoire d'un enfant qui cherche et de
l'affection et qui n'a rencontré que de
la perversité et la destruction
personnel vous écouterez à 20 heures
en attendant j'accueille stéphane
guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
là c'est plus stéphane guillon acteurs
c'est le dos et l'autre le méchant du
par des chiens c'est sale et méchant du
très bien mais d'abord le zapping voilà
c'était le zapping avoue stéphane pour
la semaine à venir
[Musique]
ce week-end interdiction de parler
politique à cause des élections
régionales c'est dommage qu'elle devrait
la branlée qu'ils ont prise infi
là la branlée le real de madrid éliminé
par lyon
[Applaudissements]
ça va pas de politique non le sait ça ne
veut pas jalili a des gens qui ont
protesté samedi dernier à cause de la
diffusion d'ushuaïa
il craignait que ça influence le vote
écologique dans ce cas là il faut aussi
interdire la chronique d'eric zemmour ce
soir sur france 2 c'est encouragent le
vote raciste
faut supprimer combien ça coûte demain à
17 heures ça encourage le vot pou jadis
tu
es dimanche dernier en recevant dorothée
michel drucker a multiplié par cent le
nombre
d'abstentionnistes on s'est tous dit
tant pis pour le vote le retour de
dorothée on ne peut pas rater ça
le film flic ou voyou était lui diffusé
à 21h35 là ça allait tirer les résultats
étaient connus de toute façon flic ou
voyou ça n'aura avantagé personne ça
concerne la plupart des hommes
politiques
et ping l'homme le plus petit du monde
est mort il mesurait 74 cm fumait comme
un pompier et multipliait les conquêtes
sexuelles
74 cm c'est pas mal humble nakba un
petit peu plus brillants et on y va la
tête la première
les producteurs de la comédie musicale
mike brant recherche l'interprète
capable d'incarner la star il faut avoir
le physique chanter juste et surtout
pratiquer le saut à l'élastique c'est
pour le final tous les soirs mike se
jettera dans le vide
[Applaudissements]
aux jeux paralympiques de vancouver
toujours pas de médaille pour la france
faut dire qu'on est très pénalisée par
rapport à un pays comme le rwanda qui
affiche plus de 130 athlètes amputés nos
no4 accidenté de moissonneuses batteuses
on est ridicule
[Applaudissements]
plus d'infos intéressantes les
secouristes ont beaucoup moins de
travail que lors des jeux pour valides
en effet hier dans la descente hommes
quand les deux tibias de l'américain
woods ont volé dans la poudreuse trois
minutes plus tard le temps de les re
cliquez sur ses genoux il était sur pied
à d'évacuation en hélico pas de
rééducation tout ce bordel
pierre cardin regrette de ne pas avoir
eu d'enfant avec jeanne moreau
peut-être pas trop tard
si à 6 si on me dit dans l'oreillette
qu'il est trop tard
le week-end dernier un festival de
playmobil s'est tenue à mont-saint-éloi
des centaines de figurines étaient
exposés en revanche mireille mathieu qui
a inventé la célèbre coiffure playmobil
n'était pas présente
[Musique]
attention aux nids de poule
oui avec le retour des beaux jours il ya
des nids de poule donc faux les faux les
contourner
oui bon on n'a pas droit de parler de
politique alors moi je
[Applaudissements]
sébastien cauet regrette que ses parents
ne l'ait pas vu réussir ah bah non non
non c'est nous c'est beaucoup mieux ils
sont morts apaisé
jean pierre coffe qui adore déjeuner au
george o 5 fait de la pub pour les
produits alimentaires leader price un
mariage totalement inattendu titre le
point pourquoi de ça mais ils sont très
très bons points est-ce qu'on peut
m'apporter un plat cuisiné leader price
c'est un kebab au boulgour
genre bateaux sont élus au moins un
bassin où ça sent bon j'ai
zappé
amène à passer à l'essai
dont le poulet abete
se régale
écoutez ça
merci jean pierre
de rien mais a tenu bon les pauvres
faites pas chier
acheter des produits leader price ça
permet à jean pierre de se taper la
poche aujourd'hui
non
il a sur canalplus.fr on passe
maintenant à notre invité du samedi
par joël re bonsoir avant d'aborder
d'autres histoires jouer qu'on regarde
un édito de blacko
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez bien trudon
d'inscrire ses enfants au catéchisme
si c'est pour apprendre l'amour du
prochain pourquoi pas mais bon y'a des
limites alors d'accord tous les curés ne
sont pas pédophiles n'empêche ya des
curés pédophiles barthou le scandale à
d'abord éclaté aux états unis puis en
irlande au brésil aux pays-bas en
autriche en allemagne aussi où le frère
du pape est accusé de ne pas avoir
dénoncé les abus sexuels commis dans la
chorale qui dirigeait et le pape lui
qu'est ce qu'il dit
est là en 2008 à sydney benoît 16 a déjà
présenté les excuses de l'église aux
victimes australienne peut-être qu'ils
devraient renouveler ses excuses mais
cette fois dans toutes les langues au
balcon de la place saint pierre
aujourd'hui pour que l'église prouve sa
volonté de lutter contre la pédophilie
certains voudraient qu'elle renonce au
célibat des prêtres malheureusement même
si les curés devenait père de famille ça
ne réglerait pas forcément le problème
car en france
75% des cas d'agressions sexuelles sur
mineurs jugés au tribunal sont des cas
d'inceste
maltraitances et violences sexuelles sur
mineurs se taire c'est laisser faire
voilà c'était les hits de blacko mise en
image de julien gracq alors joël peau de
famille
habite un petit village belge à la
frontière de la france de la belgique et
du luxembourg qui s'appelle au bond des
gens assez pauvre votre père et grutiers
dans une casse automobile
votre mère femme au foyer les trois
frères une soeur et vous avez huit ans
quand votre père père hanoi dans un
accident de voiture et du même coup il
perd son travail
il se réfugie dans la boisson
mais moi je ne lui en veux pas du tout
parce que à sa place j'aurais fait
pareil ouais son accident si la salle
lyon il avait 33 ans donc
avec les enfants à nourrir ouais alors
là vous avez du mal à étudier chez vous
au milieu d'un père alcoolique et de
deux frères très bruyant et vous
rapprocher du vicaire c'est à dire du
curé du village et des religieuses qui
l'entourent et là c'est assez agréable
finalement pas ce que vous sentez aimé
et choyés à ce moment là je les prenais
comme ma famille quoi ouais voilà je
faisais mes devoirs chez eux je faisais
leur jardin avec eux tous alex vous
devenez un petit peu joël le sacristain
de la paroisse à ce moment là déjà 8 ans
voilà et vous vous envisagez même à
l'époque de devenir prêtre ça vous
semble parce qu'ils me pour moi c'est un
bon exemple de vie voilà alors c'est
alors que le vicaire tombe malade et
arrive un nouveau qui s'appelle la baie
il a 27 ans oui les jeunes c'est sa
première paroisse ouais il attire les
enfants du village parce que chez lui il
ya des jeux il ya des consoles nintendo
il ya il ya un baby-foot enfin les
jeunes viennent facilement chez lui il
faut dire que c'était en 87 donc il est
à l'avant-garde comme je dis maintenant
ce serait l'ordinateur il aurait
l'ordinateur chez lui tout bien sûr bien
sûr alors il ya un truc nous sommes
quand même bizarre c'est que dans son
bureau qu'on vous y allez vous découvrez
beaucoup de photos d'enfants encadrés
comme un marin c'est surprenant et un
fauteuil c'est tout il ya la télévision
un fauteuil dont chaque fois que des
enfants venaient il fallait qu'ils se
mettent alors souffler sur les
accoudoirs sur ses genoux ou artères sur
le tapis mais ça c'est calculé c'est un
laitage donc c'était réservé pour les
enfants et quand il recevait des adultes
ils les kosovars en bas
alors il vous invite à aller le voir
quand vous arrivez il ferme les volets
il allume la tv et il vous demande
effectivement de vous asseoir sur ses
genoux et moi comme j'avais un petit
frère qui venait de naître
gt1 vous n'avez pas trop eu d'affection
dans ma famille comme ça et de voir mon
petit frère dans les bras de maman tout
ça et qu'après je voyais tous des
enfants c'est le prêtre moi je me suis
dit pourquoi pas moi vous êtes donc lui
me disait ma vient tard le soir on sera
tous les on sera que tous les deux et
tout de suite ça a dérapé alors il
commence si vous caresse le haut du
corps il vous caresse le visage
et un jour il vous dit laisse toi faire
sur un ton qui n'est pas un ordre mais
quand même relativement autoritaire
voilà et moi je n'aimais pas je fermais
toujours mes yeux alors là il commence à
vous caressez sous vos vêtements de plus
en plus bas il vous embrasse mais sur
les joues sur les oreilles c'est quand
on y repense et des boutin qui n'avait
pas vous sais même pas de quoi il
s'agissait voila voila c'était en 87
avant les affaires du trou la sexualité
je connaissais rien du tout ouais vous
dites il vient donc voila depuis je fais
pas attention aux plus jeunes quand je
pensais que ça normal ouais voilà ils
vous demandent quand même au bout d'un
moment et vous demande permet des choses
plus précises vous ils vous force à le
masturber forcé des fellations enfin
même aller plus loin mais ça j'ai
toujours résisté comme louis quand vous
dormez chez lui mais il essaye d'aller
plus loin dans la vie voilà et vous
refusez à ce moment-là trouver parce que
ça c'est pour moi déjà je voyais que
penser de la bestialité enfin
alors vous décidez d'en parler à
l'évêque auxiliaire du diocèse et puis
vous n'avez pas de réponse et vous
pensez en fait que ces pratiques sont
habituelles parce que j'avais pas de
référence voilà s'il ne répond pas c'est
que ça normal quelques temps après il a
quand même dû partir la tête il a été
dans une autre paroisse près de namur et
là il a recommencé il est resté dans
l'église n'a pas été exclu de l'église
rien en aucun cas alors vous devenez
séminaristes découvrez que le
psychologue qui est chargé de soigner
votre timidité est en fait complice de
toutes ces magouilles dire qu'on fait
pendant pendant que vous le racontez vos
histoires lui ce fait un risque est
qu'au cas il s'en fout il répond au
téléphone tout ça moi elle me dit mme
allongé sur un divan je dois sentir le
coeur battre au bout de mes doigts et
trois quarts d'heure après si j'ai senti
le coeur battre au bout de mes doigts ou
pas il s'en fout que je dise oui ou non
et oui l'argent c'est tout ouais mais
après des années après je me suis rendu
compte que je m'étais laissé mené en
bateau lorsque ce gars là est devenu
prêtre après donc l'évêque m'envoyer
chez ce psychologue parce qu'il savait
que ça allait rester et tout fait quand
enfin la baie
reconnaîtra les faits l'église vous
encouragera ne pas porter plainte devant
la justice des hommes en vous disant ça
doit se régler entre nous voilà mais
déjà il n'a pas avoué rapidement ouais
parce qu'un pédophile n'avoue jamais il
faut des preuves et avoir des preuves
c'est difficile mais moi chaque fois que
je lui écrivais lui me répondait elle me
disait je ne le ferai plus je
recommencerai plus j'ai tout gardé et
donc quand il a nié à l'évêché il ya une
réunion au tribunal de l'église il a nié
mais j'ai dit je vais apporter les
lettres elle elle a dit non ben savage à
vous
et là il a demandé un arrangement il
fallait pas et allait la faire sur la
place publique et voulait un arrangement
à l'amiable donc lévesque avait dit bon
on payera ton psychologue un tiers le
prêtre fautif l'autre tiers et toi
l'autre tiers parce que si tu payes pas
une partie de la thérapie elle marchera
pas ça c'est le psychologue caddie ils
n'ont jamais tenu cet engagement voilà
vous êtes exclu du séminaire de 300 et
ils font traîner les choses pour l'oscar
moi il ya prescription voilà en belgique
ces dix ans après la majorité 1
alors ce n'est qu'à 27 ans que vous
déciderez de porter plainte alors
effectivement au procès il est finale
serait terrible entre pédéraste épées
des fibres parce qu'ils disent à 14 ans
et un adolescent c'est plus de la
pédophilie c'est de la pédérastie puis
même il est venu en dire que c'est moi
qui demandait ouais ouais vous dites ils
ont volé mon corps ils ont détruit ma
foi
moi je ne crois plus en rien depuis
parce que l'évêque est là pour dire la
parole de dieu soit disant
je me suis rendu compte que l'évêque m'a
menti sans arrêt donc comment croire
après à leur baratin l'église voilà et
c'est ça le problème je pense avec la
les pédophiles prêtre c'est que il
confesse tous les jours et il se dit
j'ai le pouvoir de pardonner au nom de
dieu n'importe quoi dieu lui va me
pardonner aussi aujourd'hui vous n'avez
plus la foi non non non non
j'ai un chien c'est grâce à lui que je
vis pour lui voilà c'est ça mon soutien
c'est tout est-ce que vous avez une
connaissance d'autres cas de nouveau
plusieurs fois il a donné le bain
d'autres enfants devant moi c'est pas le
rôle d'un prêtre
ouais mais selon vous pour toi l'église
a tellement mal à régler ce genre de
problème parce que peu de victimes
haussent porter plainte déjà ouais alors
il ya déjà beaucoup de prêtres
pédophiles qui abusent mais ça se sait
jamais après il meurt personne n'a porté
plainte contre eux 2 si quelqu'un ose le
dire à leurs parents maman le curé faire
ça la maman elle va avoir peur d'eux osé
porter plainte du qu'en dira-t-on des
voisins tout ça donc elle va les trouver
lévesque et dire voilà je sais ça
déplacé le prêtre où on porte plainte
riendeau qui vont déplacer le prêtre
sans rien faire mais le prêtre ailleurs
va recommencer et la famille les parents
ils sont contents parce que conseil ne
le voit plus il faut des preuves aussi
c'est difficile de dire on va pas aller
commencer à dire voilà le prête m'abuse
mais il faut des preuves et 3 si
quelqu'un leur va aller porter plainte
les ex va essayer de faire des
arrangements à l'amiable pour palais en
justice c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire
avec moi et moi j'ai toujours refusé je
préfère même perdre les procès et pas
avoir un franc que ne parlait procès est
d'abord de l'argent de l'église parce
que le prêt de lui il s'en sortir est
trop bien joué je voudrais que s'il est
prête pouvaient se marier comme les
pasteurs ou comme les rabbins ce serait
mieux non il ya beaucoup de pédophilie
inceste dans des familles donc si le
prêt de ce mari va déjà abusé de ses
enfants donc voilà il y en a plein qui
vont dire qu'ils ont des copines qui
sont ça c'est aussi un autre problème
que un tabou que l'église ne dit pas
mais il ya le célibat c'est de la
connerie oui il y en a plein qui sont
repères
mais aussi l'église tout est bien
calculé dans le notre père par exemple
pardonne nous nos offenses comme nous
pardonnons aussi à ceux qui nous ont
offensés donc d'office à la tête non le
prêt de ma fait du mal je dois lui
pardonner parce que dieu me demande de
pardonner j'ai mis une lettre d'un prêt
dans le livre et qui m'insultent parce
que je crache sur l'église soit disant
c'est de la foutaise mais je m'en
foutais parce que je me réjouis de votre
côté voilà voilà est ce que vous croyez
que benoit 16 va vraiment s'attaquer à
ce problème ça c'est de l'hypocrisie
puisque en irlande il ya eu des
scandales découvert par l'état ils ont
fait une commission d enquête
qu a duré des années il ya quatre
évêques qui ont démissionné le pape n'a
déjà accepté la démission que de 1 mais
là le pape parle de l'irlande mais si on
lit ses discours il ya quatre ans il
parlait déjà de l'irlande donc c'est
chaque fois des excuses mais à part ça
il ya rien et ici en belgique il ya un
effet qu'un procès en cours il a une
promotion ça va pas il ya d'autres
prêtres qui sont pédophiles ils n'ont
pas de problèmes on les déplace de
paroisses c'est tout je connais il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ne sont que les
victimes devraient médiatisé est comme
ça la bombe les quatre et une fois pour
toutes en amérique ils ont été obligés
de payer quand même un oui mais le
premier lion de dollars voilà les
données par l'église catholique mais là
des enfants victimes du pédophile comme
un mort ça c'est pas bien c'est ce que
je dis dans le livre parce que là en
payant le procès n'a pas eu lieu oui ils
ont accepté un arrangement à l'amiable
ça c'est pas bien dix mois joël ils ont
bousillé votre vicois ont bien sûr et
moi non papa est mort à 59 ans et jamais
josé lui en parler il a vu ça dans un
journal un jour que j'avais autorisé de
même ma photo je suis né dans le fin
fond de la belgique j'habite à bruxelles
je me suis exilé à bruxelles parce que
j'avais peur d'aller dans mon village
parce que des gens croyaient que
les rumeurs tout ça que c'était moi le
pédophile donc moi on m'avait mis dehors
du séminaire parce que j'étais pédophile
alors que j'ai été abusée et que le
prêtre lui il se pavane partout ça va
pas
c'est le monde à l'envers puis moi j'ai
médiatiser la faire aussi et puis j'ai
porté plainte parce que je sais qu'il
faisait ça à d'autres et je voulais que
d'autres plaintes et et qu'il aille en
prison c'est sa place mais voilà c'est
vrai il ya plus de tolérance de la
société sur ces choses là non ce n'est
pas parce que c'est une honte c'est un
tabou on n'ose pas le voir
merci de votre témoignage entre les
casuals
voilà c'était ça l'idée terrien des
christian louboutin
pour l'ensemble de son oeuvre
jean bien cave
rami à petit prix ces plantes aïssa
maïga rester femme dit pour le temps de
la kermesse est terminé de frédéric
chignac tabriz nicolino beau biden
aux éditions les liens qui libèrent et
joël 2000 et pour violer par un prêtre
éditions de l'arbre merci à toute
l'équipe qui m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission on se retrouve samedi à 19
heures et du sida sur canalplus.fr je
vous laisse avec mes amis d'action
discrète et de groland magzine salut les
terriens
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus